citizens of the reject Nation we are
going to watch the official trailer or
trailer dose for black panther wakanda
forever John good morning 6 a.m how are
you I am wide awake and ready to go how
are you I'm ready to go too got tickets
leave a like leave a like and let's
see what's going on in this trailer
only the most broken people
can't be great leaders
wow guys
the feather serpent God oh [__]
wow Eternal War he's coming
in the surface world coming to the surface World
know what you whisper whoa stand
oh is that I hurt
laughs
oh my God yes
oh [__] whoa I didn't think we had
jealous yeah damn this looks great oh
wow wow that was pulse pounding exciting it was
beautiful I feel like both these trailers have
been some of Marvel's best trailers they've
ever done like the first one was like they're
both emotional in their own ways I mean the first
one you know obviously broke me but uh this one
was very uh just sweeping and pulse pounding and
felt like inspiring it felt that like motivation
in there to fight for something you know and I I
mean okay we gotta talk about the suit It's gotta
be sure and that [__] almost like a shirt
that's in Baku definitely a box yeah uh yeah
definitely it looks like it's a shuri outfit in
the way they just composed the trailer which uh
I'm I'm excited for to see I wonder if they're
gonna do a situation where it would be Sherry
being black panther but would she also be the
leader you know and I'm curious to see if if it
is sure it looks like it is sure I'm gonna leave
with the idea that it sure yeah you would have to
see her really grow quite a bit into to being like
the Ultimate Warrior though because you know we
didn't really see much of her train to be like
she can fight but to be the Black Panther as a
whole other skill set level you got to sort of
be at in which he be the the leader of wakanda
after that you know that's something to unpack
but in terms of what we're immediately getting
yeah it looks like we're dealing with post the
loss of t'challa like the the way the funeral is
being captured looks obviously very mournful and
sorrowful at the same time it looks like with the
way the least is being represented culturally at
the beginning of this trailer that it would also
be a celebration as well of the legacy of t'challa
simultaneously you know working on the celebration
of Chadwick Boseman as well so yeah and then you
got anymore flying around with his little little
wings Little Wings on his ankles yeah man and I
loved what they made of that because the first
trailer has so much mystery about Neymar and about
Atlantis in general and here you see I feel like
from both perspectives It's like because we know
wakanda much better you know we feel like that
so what our comfort zone is but yeah you know
most of the world has only just learned about
this and I feel like now they've kind of created
a similar feeling with Atlantis where it's like
now we get to see kind of from the wakandan's
perspective of you know okay we've got this sort
of mystical leader and his you know people who are
now coming for us and I love to the way like the
Espionage Espionage flavors kind of compliment
that because you know you're bringing those out
of the original black panther but it also seems
like that element of the story is probably going
to lead directly into the looming conflict
between the wakandans and the atlanteans and
then whatever you know eventual Alliance comes
of that you know I think will be hard one but
yeah like there's so much in purpose and in you
know this conflict and you can feel that rousing
quality I don't know yeah it's like there's a
rousing sort of aspirational there's a very sort
of like heart heavy life quality about what the
wakanans are obviously going through and I feel
like that underpinning will make for like a really
interesting ideological debate too once they act
actually finally get to like peeling back
each other's motivations and realizing that
they probably have a common enemy or something
like that well in grief oftentimes family has
to come together during that point so I think
that's what this trailer really seemed to hone
in on for for me personally was the the sense of
loss and that's where the the motivational part
comes from is of fighting together is that now I
mean part of wakanda is that they've always been
together but now more than ever would that pain
imbued into everyone's performances and their
motivation and what they have to fight for you
know like losing t'challa they're probably viewed
as being a little bit weaker now and now they have
to really prove their strength I really feel like
uh I forget her name didn't I had to pronounce
her name deny Guerrera Guerra Guerrero Guerrera
her performance in the in this Trail like just
looks so powerful and looks like she's gonna get
a really badass fight scene too absolutely uh
when in that car or whatever the hell is going
on there and then you see ironheart flying around
a lot more we still don't exactly know what it is
I mean you could kind of like pull from Comics
it may be some other ideas from like the previous
trailer of why Namor is fighting specifically but
from what the actor has talked about recently is
that this character is definitely going to be
more portrayed more so as an anti-hero more
so than a direct villain I'm excited for that
to get like a Latin character in here and then
to see the cultures being represented like
that just expanding upon that even more so I
think it's going to be exciting and great and the
representation I think would be very powerful and
his performance does look intimidating I'm glad
that they still have kept him a mystery for the
most part because it there's a lot a lot of things
that have to shine in this movie and then you have
to introduce all these other aspects as well while
dealing with a real the passing of t'challa Slash
Chadwick Boseman there's so much that this film
has to do in one the run time is two hours and 41
minutes when I bought the tickets this morning I
was like okay this really is two hours 41 minutes
which I think is a great run time especially with
all those qualities you have to jam packed into
one film yeah I mean we got Iron Art here Namor
coming to the surface and uh does feel threatening
and Angela Bassett looks great as well and Baku
looks awesome like every uh it this this feels
um like a Monumental point for the Marvel films
and I I it doesn't look funny it looks cultural
and purposeful and heavy and like there will
be some kind of if it is shuri I bet there's a
really really vital coming of age in a rough
you know situation story that that you can
ring out I think the fact that they showed it is
the thing that like surprised me the most that's
like because it could be Okoye it could be and
that's what gets me wondering if yeah if they're
misleading us or if they're I don't know you
know if there might be if she might Don the Black
Panther suit but maybe there will be somebody
else who works alongside her in a capacity like
it it feels like there's a definitive aspect but
it's not the whole picture you know yeah all right
guys well that's the Black Panther wakanda forever
official trailer what did you all think leave your
thoughts down below and be sure to subscribe click
that Bell leave a like we'll catch you all soon